eu sempre falei que me conhece sabe que
tem três momentos especiais na vida de
cada pessoa
o dia de seu nascimento o dia que foi o
primeiro dia do resto da sua vida e o
dia da sua morte
e essa é a grande pergunta qual é o
primeiro dia do resto da sua vida o meu
foi em 2006
eu costumo dizer que o dia do clique é o
dia que as coisas parecem fazer sentido
a partir dali as coisas começam a fazer
sentido e eu tinha 25 anos
eu vivia no alto dos meus privilégios
dentro de uma bolha em salvador a cidade
que eu nunca saí tinha um relacionamento
estável tinha me formado em direito
trabalhava no escritório de advocacia
casamento marcado uma vida muito boa até
que nada fazia mais sentido um clique
não fazia mais sentido o relacionamento
acabou o escritório não fazia parte
daquilo que eu queria e eu resolvi mudar
resolvi sair da bolha e eu resolvi e por
uma área que eu nunca tinha ouvido falar
nunca tinha aprendido a nunca tinha
escutado nem na faculdade fui fazer um
estado em direitos humanos na frança
fui embora pela primeira vez tinha que
me virar sozinha tinha que voltar atrás
tinha que deixar de receber salários
tinha que voltar sua estagiária
voluntária e começa a aprender uma série
de outras coisas que eu nunca tinha tido
acesso e muita coisa a partir dali
começou a se encaixar
eu não sabia porque as coisas
funcionavam daquela maneira só sabia que
ela estava funcionando e eu fui seguindo
o fluxo e esse foi o dia 11
é o dia que eu reconheço que de fato eu
entendi que o meu lugar no mundo deveria
ser um pouco próximo daquilo que eu
estava tendo acesso saindo desse
processo de estudo eu fui pra áfrica e
eu comecei a trabalhar na república
democrática do congo que é o país número
um em violência contra a mulher é um dos
piores índices de desenvolvimento humano
do mundo é um país muito complicado não
só pelas violências mas pela própria
questão que há décadas existe um
genocídio na nas fronteiras do país é
muito pouco se fala sobre isso e ali
todos os meus de estereótipos se
quebravam todos os dias
cada dia que eu sair na rua e descobriu
a uma nova realidade
tudo que eu acreditava tudo que eu
lutava parecendo fazer mais sentido
porque cada dia eu era confrontada com
novas perspectivas com novas histórias
com novas pessoas e ali eu entendo que
foi o segundo momento da minha vida que
eu comecei a enxergar
comecei a sair da bolha e realmente
encherga voltando para o brasil
eu fui trabalhar em são paulo e aí eu
comecei a trabalhar segundas quartas e
sextas com pessoas em situação de
cárcere terças e quintas com os
refugiados que chegaram em são paulo e
durante esse período foi um período
muito difícil com histórias muito densas
e um confrontava encontrava pessoas que
me tiraram da minha zona de conforto
pessoas que me contavam histórias de
cruzar fronteiras que faziam com que eu
mesma cruzasse as minhas próprias
fronteiras
eu precisava passar as minhas fronteiras
os meus limites para entender aquela
pessoa que conversava comigo eu
precisava passar o meu muro pra entender
aquela pessoa que estava dentro do muro
eu precisava romper com isso comprou meu
controle isso me trouxe uma série de
frustrações
essas frustrações acumuladas me
trouxeram uma doença e eu passei dois
anos sofrendo com as inflamações que
fazia com que eu não enxergasse eu tinha
uma doença nos olhos durante dois anos
eu fui pra todos os médicos possíveis eu
fiz todos os exames possíveis eu fui
fonte de pesquisa de universidade e eu
não tinha nenhuma causa física e as
informações continuavam vindo e eu parei
pra perceber que talvez eu precisasse
olhar para o meu emocional
talvez a causa não fosse física eu
estivesse procurando da medicina uma
resposta que a medicina não ia me dar
e essa foi a terceira vez que eu comecei
a enxergar o mundo
e na verdade eu percebi que precisava
mudar a lente que fazia com que ele
enxergasse o mundo eu vi enxergando de
uma forma mas a lente estava errada eu
precisava trazer uma lente de alegria
mesmo na dor mesmo na tristeza eu
precisava trazer uma lente de empoderar
as outras pessoas
usava sobretudo trazer uma lente de
horizontalidade
hoje em dia os trabalhadores
humanitários a gente sofre muito de
doenças físicas porque não existe um
cuidado com o cuidador
ninguém pensa em cuidar de quem cuida e
muitas vezes as pessoas acham que os
trabalhadores humanitários são pessoas
boas
são voluntários são pessoas religiosas e
na verdade não são os profissionais
técnicos que realizamos um trabalho em
campo que é um trabalho e precisamos de
ajuda de uma rede de apoio
muitas pessoas adoecem porque essa rede
não existe não é ainda uma rede
sustentável e isso aconteceu comigo
nesse momento é ao mudar a lente eu
percebia que a gente precisava enxergar
o outro além da superfície deixar de
enxergar através de estereótipos deixar
de enxergar através da responsabilidade
que eu tenho deixar de enxergar através
da culpa que muitas vezes o que acontece
e não passar a enxergar o futuro esse
mundo que existe
tá ruim é ruim pra todo mundo mas ele
está fadado a acabar essa estrutura uma
estrutura velha há uma estrutura falida
ea gente precisa construir o novo então
precisava tirar energia da destruição
daquilo que eu queria destruir combater
pra colocar a minha energia naquilo que
eu queria construir trazer a energia por
bem trazer energia pensando na
construção das novas estruturas do
futuro que a gente vai viver ou as
futuras gerações vão viver e com isso eu
consegui
nunca mais tem inflamações na vista
simplesmente sumiram e eu continuei
trabalhando com isso
nesse mesmo momento quando tinha essa
reflexão aconteceu caso do da morte do
menino arlan que me fez pensar muito
porque conversava muito com esse meu
momento de vida essa foto rodou o mundo
e por algum motivo eu não entendia por
que essa foto específica e esse menino
específico tinham chamado tanto a
atenção todos os países do mundo todas
as pessoas as pessoas de coração mais
duro do mundo publicaram esta foto eu
queria saber por quê
é porque eu ir lá não foi o primeiro e
não foi o último a menina morreu numa
praia e aí eu fiz uma reflexão que me
levou à seguinte conclusão
esse menino além de ser um menino branco
bem vestido calçado isso já chama a
atenção ele é um menino sem identidade
o rosto dele não aparece
isso faz com que a gente não olhe ele
ninguém enxerga o ilan você enxerga o
seu filho se enxerga o seu sobrinho e
enxerga seu afilhado em xeque a pessoa
que você ama porque a gente projeta
aquilo que a gente ama nesta foto
ninguém procura saber cadê os pais do
alan
se ele tem irmãos de onde eles saíram o
que levou eles saírem da onde eles
saíram para onde estavam indo quais eram
os sonhos dessa família
ninguém procura saber isso não saiu na
mídia então na verdade eu cheguei a uma
conclusão que é uma conclusão que a
gente precisa amar aquilo que a gente
não conhece porque a gente é
condicionado a amar aquilo que a gente
conhece aquilo que parece com a gente
aquilo que tem o nosso rosto que tem o
nosso cromossomo e não é assim
a gente só vai conseguir trazer esse
mundo novo quando essa estrutura de amor
se amplie a huai'an ele é uma dos 65
milhões de pessoas em deslocamento
forçado no mundo hoje enquanto a gente
está aqui conversando existem 17 guerras
ativas no mundo e isso gera um fluxo de
pessoas não só para os países clássicos
que pra europa mas também muitos vindos
e chegando ao brasil nosso continente é
um fluxo importante de pessoas o maior
desde a segunda guerra mundial ea gente
vai precisar tomar uma atitude e tomaram
na sua responsabilidade diante desse
cenário
todas as reflexões juntas me fizeram
pensar que eu deveria fazer alguma coisa
ok entendi entende que é preciso fazer
alguma coisa oq né e aí
durante esses anos de trabalho eu
conheci muitas mulheres e muitas
mulheres incríveis com histórias
absolutamente incríveis ea gente começou
a formar algumas conversas
as rodas de conversa entre mulheres e
decidimos criar uma rede de apoio
interna porque porque a solidão da
mulher refugiada é uma solidão muito
dura é uma mulher que saiu de tudo que
ela conhecia abandonou toda sua história
todo seu passado toda sua família sua
casa tudo aquilo que você conhece como o
mundo
você foi tirada arrancada dali e
colocada no novo contexto onde você não
conhece ninguém onde você não fala a
língua onde a sua integração é difícil
então primeira proposta a gente criar
uma rede de apoio interna entre a gente
onde a gente pudesse conversar onde o
ambiente fosse livre onde não existe
nenhum tipo de restrição
depois na sequência a gente começou a
pensar que a gente podia um pouquinho
mais além disso
e aí a gente queria criar um movimento
de conscientização falar pro brasil
falar para os outros países falar para
as pessoas o que é o refúgio porque
essas pessoas chegaram até aqui quem são
essas pessoas
bonfim a gente queria sensibilizar e
sensibilizar através das histórias de
mulheres e história sobretudo
relacionadas à violência de gênero
são diversas as violência de gênero que
causam o deslocamento de pessoas
mutilação genital mais casamentos
forçados mulheres estupradas em zonas de
guerra
diferentes formas de violência é
direcionado a opinião política de
mulheres a feministas à orientação
sexual
então a gente queria evidenciar esse
tipo de de violência ea gente cria um
projeto chamado projeto vidas refugiados
que foi o quarto momento que eu
enxerguei na minha vida e o vírus e
forjadas agora tá fazendo dois anos é um
projeto criado coletivamente por um
grupo de mulheres para mulheres ea gente
depois e desde essa roda de conversa a
gente criou uma exposição fotográfica
que vem rodando o país passou em porto
alegre passou por várias outras capitais
ea gente vem trazendo fotografias de
mulheres e é estão refugiados no brasil
hoje e que de uma certa forma querem
contar a sua história são mulheres que
querem falar
e pra mim foi muito importante para
se para esse movimento porque cada uma
delas me ensinou de uma forma muito
precisa
coisas muito particulares então a maria
é uma cubana que está no brasil há
quatro anos ea maioria definitivamente
foi a pessoa que me ensinou a ter
coragem acreditar no meu potencial
a maria um dia bateu na minha mesa numa
sala cheia de pessoas onde ela não
conhecia ninguém e ela falou eu vim para
o seu país porque eu precisava de ajuda
mas eu não vou lavar banheiro de
brasileiro eu sou um intelectual eu sou
antropólogos o doutora e hoje ela está
traçando o caminho dela com a cabeça
erguida ela me ensinou isso a maior da
síria ela me ensinou uma forma muito
bonita que a gente pode ser várias em
uma só
mãe de duas adolescentes esposa diretora
do departamento da universidade de
damasco uma mulher incrível que hoje em
dia trabalha acolhendo crianças
refugiadas e ensinando francês acilve é
uma mulher com goleada e essa pequenina
no braço dela é a gabriela brasileira
que nasceu aqui e ela me ensinou a ser
tolerante
ela me ensinou a ter paciência de
escutar às vezes eu tenho opiniões muito
rápidas e um pouco radicais inflexíveis
e acilve ela me mostrou uma outra forma
de pensar uma forma de pensar diferente
da minha e ela me ensinou isso através
do amor da paciência você amar outra
pessoa e respeitar o ponto de vista dela
é completamente diferente do seu
alice é uma menina do burkina fasso e
ela tem uma frase que ela fala se
refugiado é ser livre e isso é linda é
uma jovem que deixou uma carreira para
trás deixou a família dela veio sozinha
para o brasil e ela é destemida ela me
ensinou a ter coragem ela me ensinou a
ser livre
ela me ensinou aí pra frente a janeth é
uma mulher absolutamente incrível é uma
das histórias mais tristes de vida que
eu já ouvi e ao mesmo tempo é uma
fortaleza absoluta uma mulher que
consegue passar por tudo que ela passou
e te ter a certeza
existe uma manhã ter a certeza de que
existe uma força superior que protege
ela e ter a certeza de quem ela é e que
tudo vai dar certo
havia uma é a nossa casa linha do
projeto ela chegou aqui com 17 anos
angolana e ela tem uma frase que é nunca
desista
tente e se dê errado pente de novo então
ela definitivamente me ensinou a tentar
nunca desistir dos meus sonhos ea
jonathan nigeriana é um dos corações
desse projeto
uma mulher incrível que me ensinou muito
sobre o papel da mulher no mundo sobre o
que nós podemos fazer como as mulheres
nós temos um papel de ajudar outras
mulheres de olhar para outras mulheres e
ela um dia me falou que as mulheres têm
um coração maior que os homens e é por
isso que nós estamos mais fortes e
recentemente na semana passada
acompanhou a entrevista da jonathan e
ela falou pra repórter
a repórter perguntou pra ela se tinha
valido a pena ela ter feito tudo que ela
fez e tem se colocado em risco e ter
fugido do país dela e ela respondeu pra
repórter aqui não é uma questão de
dinheiro a vida é sobre fazer outras
pessoas felizes e que ela não se
arrepende de nada
então eu acho que é isso a mensagem para
a gente construir um mundo novo é a
gente buscar a felicidade das outras
pessoas
obrigado
[Aplausos]